at Ted we're passionate about public
speaking
whether sharing from a stage a podcast
in a classroom or at work being able to
effectively share your ideas can have a
huge impact on your life and the world
that's why we've spent the last two
years developing this a new mobile app
that's fully dedicated to helping you
learn the arts of identifying developing
and sharing your best ideas Ted
masterclass features a beautifully
animated 11 lesson course choice TED
Talks that model the concepts covered in
each lesson and a continuous flow of
exclusive insights from Ted's speaker
coaching team you can move through the
course at your own pace and each lesson
will help you master a discrete
presentation skill first you'll learn
how to identify develop and distill your
best ideas next if you learn how to
prepare yourself for presenting those
ideas and finally you'll learn a variety
of techniques that'll help you deliver
your talk in ways that will resonate in
the minds of your listeners you can
download the mobile app and preview
every lesson in the course for free and
if you decide to purchase the full
course all proceeds will support the
nonprofit work of Ted's global education
initiative Ted ed learning how to
effectively share your best ideas
creates opportunities for both you and
your audience take the first step
towards mastering the art of public
speaking by checking out Ted masterclass
today
[Music]